Speaker 1: The real mental health issue might
actually be the Republican Party. The there is
a new piece in The New Republic by Michael
Tomasky called The main mental health issue
in this country is in the Republican Party. And
this piece makes a number of really good points.
One of the points that the piece makes, and I
encourage you to read it, is that red states
allocate way less money for treating mental
illness than do blue states. And in fact, if you
look at a map and we're putting such a map up on
the screen, you can see that generally speaking,
red states are much lighter colored, meaning
they devote a much smaller share of their budgets
towards mental health treatment that we know.
And so at a baseline level, this is a bad start.
When you look back at the last many years,
there has really only been one major expansion
of mental health spending and coverage,
and it's called the Affordable Care Act,
also known as Obamacare. Remember, Obamacare
and the Affordable Care Act are the same thing.
I know it's wild that I have to mention
that, but I do. And Republicans regularly
vote against all other attempts, as I've talked
about with Greg Abbott or we will talk about with
Greg Abbott. As I talked about with Congressman
Tony Gonzales, Republicans regularly vote against
attempts to increase funding and increase access
to mental health treatment. So at a core level,
when we say mental health, mental illness, red
states are disproportionately under-funded when
it comes to access. So it's a perfectly logical
conclusion. You've got more Republicans than
Democrats in red states. Red states have
lower funding for mental health treatment.
Increasingly, mental illness, you would expect,
would skew towards being a Republican problem.
To be clear, it doesn't mean at all that there
are millions of lefties and Democrats, etc.,
who struggle with mental illness. But when
you look at access and treatment and funding,
it's going to skew as a more as a bigger problem
to the right. But it's more than that. The problem
in terms of mental health isn't just
health care. It's also about economic
care. We know about the crushing effect on one's
mood and cognitive state and mental health status
of being unable to take time off from work. When
you need it of knowing that you're going to be
able to just pay your basic bills, of feeling
like there's no economic opportunity where you
are. And when you look at all of these different
things, when you look at right wing economic
policy versus left wing economic policy, the
economic realities of red states we know are
much more negatively impactful on mental health
and and sort of the state of one's mood than those
economic policies in blue leaning states. Again,
these are averages we're talking generally. Now,
there's another layer which Tomasky doesn't
talk about in the piece, which I want to add,
which is when we talk about a lot of these right
wing ideas, they sound almost what we might call
mentally ill. Now, I want to be really careful.
We may not literally mean mentally ill in all
of these cases. We're not stigmatizing mental
illness. We're also not using it as an insult.
But when you hear the idea. Give teachers
guns and have them defend classrooms.
It sounds like what you would say is an insane
idea. It's disconnected from reality. Only someone
who has something wrong, either significant
ignorance or some kind of mental disturbance,
would suggest, because it doesn't make any sense.
And we can go further. There was a recent poll.
20% or more of the Republican Party believes
at least some. Q and on conspiracies. Okay.
Is it literally diagnostic mental illness? No,
it's not. But a lot of this ideology borders
on people who are having some kind of block
where they're not connected to the real world.
There's a delusional nature to it. After the 2020
election. 57% of Trump voters believe that Trump
won. Trump didn't win. Joe Biden won. Joe Biden
easily won the popular vote. Joe Biden easily
won the electoral vote. No one state would have
changed that. Of the states that were in play,
Trump didn't win. Trump lost. And yet 57% of his
voters believed that he had won. At some point we
have to say, well, there's a delusional nature
to it. Is it diagnostically delusional? Well,
that you'd have to examine everybody and mental
health professionals would have to make the call.
But when we talk about mental health, the fact
that they're saying, well, just fix guns by
dealing with you, fix shootings by dealing
with mental health rather than guns. Well,
at the micro level, they vote against you doing
that all the time. They don't want to fund mental
health treatment. They don't want to do any of
it. But when we say it's a mental illness problem,
what are we really saying? And when you step back
and look at the state of American politics and you
look at where access to mental health treatment is
funded and you look at the delusional nature of a
lot of these ideas, I again, I know I always use
this example. We're not talking about a difference
as to whether the top tax rate should be 20%, 35%
or 50%. This is a different thing. We're talking
about something that is fundamentally delusional.
And you need only look at the NRA convention. You
need only look at the so-called suggestions
that they're coming up with to deal with
the gun violence issue, to see that. So I'm not
diagnosing anybody. I'm not stigmatizing mental
illness and I'm not ridiculing mental illness. I'm
also not using the term mental illness as a cudgel
to attack people with. But I am pointing out
that when we talk about mental illness broadly,
we really have to dig in to what is happening
state by state to understand the implications
of, number one, not properly funding
dealing with mental health issues.
And number two, pointing to them in some vague way
when we blame shootings. But then all of a sudden
we can say, Hey, half of the ideas associated
with Trump ism are delusional. Colloquially.
That I'm sort of at a loss for words to go
further. But I'm very curious to hear from you.
What do you think? Find me on Twitter at Pacman.
And remember that Tuesday, June 14th at 6 p.m.,
we'll be doing our next David Pakman show viewer
town hall. It will be streaming live exclusively
on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
That's our second YouTube channel.
Subscribe there and we're very much
looking forward to that next town
hall. The David Pakman Show is an audience
supported program. I would love for you to sign up
at. Join Pacman dot com and become a member. Every
day we do an extra show for our members called
the Bonus Show. We also provide a commercial free
audio stream and a commercial free video stream of
the show to our members. And we make the episodes
every single day available to our members,
sometimes some somewhere between five and 6 hours
earlier than we published the full video show.
You can sign up at join pacman dot com. You can
use the coupon code. Big voting 20 to big voting
22. Because everyone must vote in November, of
course, big voting 22. It joined Pacman dot com